Speaker 1: So we have another data point in our
building belief that Ron DeSantis simply is not
ready for prime time and would completely fail
if he did try to run against Donald Trump in the
Republican primary, which is not yet a foregone
conclusion. We're still going to have to wait and
see whether DeSantis chooses to get into this
race. A campaign for DeSantis that is rapidly
collapsing before it even starts. Ron DeSantis
had a complete and total meltdown when asked
about this former Guantanamo Bay detention center
detainee who has claimed that the Santas observed
when he was being tortured. Now, DeSantis for
a long time has been saying, no, no, no, no,
no, I wasn't I wasn't in any position of power at
the time or whatever. And DeSantis just flips out
here. And again, you can tell he is not ready to
be confronted with tough questions by journalists.
I don't think if this is how he reacts to a
simple question and gets so heated and triggered,
I don't see how he could possibly succeed on
a debate stage with Donald Trump. Check this
out. The latest. DeSantis off the handle.
Speaker 2: No, no, no, no. That's B.S. And
actually, we have a president
who said that his aides,
how would they know? Okay, you think about
it. Do you honestly believe that's credible?
So this is 22,006. I'm a junior officer.
Do you honestly think that they would have
remembered me from Adam? Of course not.
They're just trying to get into the news
because they know people like you will consume
it because it fits your preordained narrative
that you're trying to spin. Focus on the fact.
Speaker 1: That you're attacking the person.
Asking the question about newsworthy claims that
have been made is not going to get you. A lot of
supporters in many circles, including Republican
circles. A better thing to do would be to answer
the question substantively. The problem is that
in 2018, DeSantis also was asked about this,
and he sure made it sound like he was
very much involved in what was going
on at Guantanamo Bay and a facility.
Speaker 2: So it's limited. But some
of the things they would do, they would do
hunger strikes. And you actually had three
detainees that committed suicide with hunger
strike. So everything at that time was legal
in nature one way or another. So the commander
wants to know, well, how do I combat this? So
one of the jobs of the legal adviser is like, hey,
you actually can force feed. Here's what you can
do. Here's kind of the rules of that. Wow.
Speaker 1: He certainly seems to know super
specifically the exact number of
people that were subjected to this,
that or the other thing, and says he was weighing
in with opinions about exactly what to do that.
Speaker 2: So during the feeding, a group of
officers arrived with the interpreters, with the
interrogators camp systematically. So they were
behind the fence. And I saw one of them was Ron
DeSantis in a military uniform. And he was well, I
was screaming, yelling because I couldn't breathe
of the initial and was like I was bleeding because
they really insert the thick to through my nose.
So I was like calling them ask.
And he was actually laughing,
looking at the other officers and smiling.
Speaker 1: All right. Now, could this guy be
lying? Absolutely. Absolutely. But the totality
of how DeSantis is handling these questions,
given his eagerness to show how specifically
he knew about every detail of what was being
done there, do we believe that on a place as
small as Guantanamo Bay, DeSantis would have
been advising about exactly what to do and yet
never present at these events? Very difficult
to believe. Cut to now, getting angry at the
reporter for even asking the question. He is
not ready for primetime. I hope that he
does run because it's abundantly clear
that his campaign would be a complete and total
humiliating mess. Maybe he can mess up Trump's
campaign to some degree. But as far as a serious
presidential candidate, DeSantis is truly lacking